talk about your opinion on like girls
trips while we're on the while we're on
I love girls party girls I got a feeling
we've got some fans of girls trips okay
so ladies on the panel thumbs up if you
do girls trip some thumbs down if you
don't
I just don't have time to what's up okay
okay so they're fun so Nicole you know
your girlfriend say hey it's uh Becky's
girlfriend we're gonna go to Vegas on
this weekend in September you know you
want to go your answer is
Fort Lauderdale you know you pick a
place anywhere where there's going to be
booze and yelling and partying
I also don't I don't drink alcohol so I
don't know I go on like I'll go out with
a couple girls like a couple girls like
okay this is my social life I have a
couple close girlfriends I keep close to
me if I say hey let's rent a car we'll
like drive down the coast to California
stay night in Santa Barbara brunch go to
the beach whatever and come back like
that's a girls trip to me I hate Vegas
trips I hate big trips I don't do drugs
I don't drink it's like exhausting to me
so like I I don't just don't go on the
girls trips I don't know Amber what do
you like about girls trips tell me
because you did two thumbs up and you
said I love girls trips
um well my girlfriends and I will
usually go to Miami but not partying in
Miami we like to stay in Brickell
Midtown area we'd like to stay at a nice
little Resort have fun see our friends
get cocktails whatever I'm not huge in
the club scene I'll go to say you're
getting cocktails you're in Brickell you
know you meet a guy who says hey I got a
yacht we're going to be on it tomorrow
when you get your girlfriends oh yeah
got it okay
whatever you want it's on the boat is
this is this if we're in a relationship
or not
we're just talking about girls trips
right now in general I don't care
we're having fun as long as you're not
doing nothing with them it's just fun
you're having a good time
Jessica
I will do a girls trip if I'm single if
I'm not single I wouldn't do a girls
trip I just feel like a girls trip with
girls especially you know it's like four
or five of us we just want to get late
we just want to drink we just want to
smoke and forget about the world we want
to do a hangover movie okay you want to
do a hangover movie okay so let's so
let's read it
because now that we've established that
girls trips do happen What happens if
you're in a long-term committed
monogamous relationship with a guy would
you still go on a girls trip thumbs up
if you would thumbs down if you wouldn't
let's see the thumbs lady
okay we got a sideways just changing her
tune a little bit interesting
I fully support I fully support guy
trips though like I I think guys trips
are really good and really important and
I don't mind if if I'm with someone and
they go on a guy's trip yeah but it's
totally different right and Guy strip
stories are funny well yeah
so okay so I guess I'll pose this to
Nicole because I have a feeling that
you're going to push back on this
because you don't like the control thing
and you think that it's an issue so
um we're in a relationship we've been
together for a year you know and then
you say to me look
um it's my best friend's uh birthday
it's her 40th you know we have to do
this trip to whatever uh it's on this
weekend so just Mark in your calendar
and then your boyfriend then says to you
well I'm not going to have it because
I'm not going to have you go away on
girls weekends is that controlling
or is he protecting the Integrity of the
relationship because he doesn't want you
exposed to any sort of problem so this
is like a this is like a Vegas girls
trip situation Vegas Sedona Fort
Lauderdale Cancun you pick the place
yeah we're gonna hypothetically pretend
that I'm I'm into drinking and partying
and it doesn't matter if you are or you
aren't but your friends are because
you're going partying into the plates
right
so I would say for a man to say you are
not doing this
that's not appropriate he could say
something like I can go and do it but
you'd be single when you came back so
let's just put it that way
okay that's and that's fine then each
person can make their choice so I will
be single when I come back if I choose
to or I'll choose not to go so it really
depends on the value of the guy like if
he's a high enough value guy and you
respect him enough no it doesn't depend
on that no just depend on that what what
no it would depend it would depend on
yeah it would depend on
um what the trip was like who they were
like I know my girlfriends and I know
what we would do on a birthday party he
literally would have nothing to worry
about
um and so assuming he knows me and knows
my friends and knows my social life and
then he came and was like well you can
go to so and so's birthday but you'll be
single when you come back
that's I'd be like okay
[Music]
um
I guess
we're talking about girls trips we're
not talking about like you and a couple
girlfriends in a remote Cabin in the
Woods like sitting around playing
categories well that's what I do that's
what I do I think you're an outlier in
this particular scenario I think we're
talking about trips to Miami or yeah we
don't we don't know you well enough to
know what you do in your girls trip so
we're just okay that's what we're kind
of yeah we're talking about your
standard girls trip where there's gonna
be partying and boats and pools and
all this country it's our 40th birthday
it's got to be a party right
Shania you're leading in strongly on
this one you've got something to say or
a thought here
I mean
it's um hold on I have to cough
sorry
um
so yeah speaking of Miami
oh my God I'm choking now
um
speaking of Miami I know I'm very
passionate about this uh
uh so I just went to Miami for Miami
swim week and
um so it's kind of fresh in my mind
right now all the After parties what is
what is Miami
um you know for those of us who don't
know what is that like a model show or
something I think you're a model right
yeah
it's a fashion show um of course it's
swimwear though
um so it's a little bit different a
little bit more party a little bit more
like summer sort of thing yeah um so
like I said it's very fresh in my mind
um so when you brought up like oh like
the stereotypical girls trip to Miami
absolutely not I would never in a
million [__] years go to that if I
was in a relationship because that was
insane it was there was ah and like I'm
with Nicole I've never touched alcohol I
don't do drugs I don't smoke weed I
don't do anything like that I'm in bed
by 9 p.m so that yeah like is part of
your denial that you would do this is
because see because what a lot of women
like to do they like to deny what goes
on on girls trips they say oh it's just
dancing or it's just fun or it's just a
boat no big deal but you're saying you
know what goes down can you can you
Enlighten the audience a little bit I
mean it was I so I've never been on a
girls trip myself but if it's any
anything like the After parties of Miami
swim week There's drugs there's flirting
there's sex in the bathroom there's how
do you know about the drug sex in the
bathroom and flirting if you go to bed
at nine o'clock I'm confused well I had
to go to the After parties I was in the
show
um but yeah it was I'm definitely one of
those people that like sits in the
corner and just watches
um and make sure all of her friends get
home safe
um but it's it's insane it's I'll yeah
100 I'll be straight up that there's
definitely some weird [__] going down so
so is it unreasonable for a guy in a
relationship to say to his woman when
she announces that she wants to go on a
girls trip
no you can't do that if you're in a
relationship with me or go if you want
but you'll come back single I mean
there's definitely like Nicole said like
I'm exactly like you like my girls trip
would be a lot different than the
stereotypical one but if it were to be
like the stereotypical like Vegas Miami
you know something big and crazy I
definitely understand why a man would be
like you know what I'm really not
comfortable with that because you know
[__] goes down so I definitely
understand
um it also depends on how he handles it
so there's ways to kind of [__] it up
and just be like you know you can't go
on this trip then the girl's gonna get
defensive then the girl's gonna be like
well why not like you know but there's
other ways to word it to be like hey you
know this makes me uncomfortable this is
why it makes me uncomfortable and
you know please respect that you know
well Amber what do you have like your
your approach is wrong yeah okay
I want to hear Amber because she she was
like we said girls trips and she gave a
Big Woo so I wanna I wanna kind of hear
no if I'm dating a high value man I'm
gonna say hey my girlfriends and I want
to go on a girls trip we're going to go
to Miami if some crazy guy comes around
with a yacht thing I'm gonna take you
guys out pay for everything I'm gonna
call him first and ask him it's okay
what have you said
he says no Then I'm not gonna go
I just my problem with I
said moth is your approach like you're
basically saying okay the girl comes to
you is like I really want to go on this
girls trip and you're just like
no and if you go you'll be single like
if you're a good if you're a good high
value man of morals and virtues and
you're truly invested in the growth of
your woman and see that as part of your
mission is to like help her you know
mature and come into her own like why
wouldn't you say why wouldn't you be
curious and be like oh you have a girls
trip tell me about it tell me what you
like about growth like listen to her get
her feedback have a conversation about
it and like yes express it like hey this
is what I this is
what girls trips to me tell me if I'm
wrong is this a girls trip etc etc but
for someone if she's saying I want to go
on this girls trip and you're just like
no I don't want you to go and if you go
you come back single it's like
you can't even have a conversation
you're shutting someone down
and that's just like it's just not
attractive in a man I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out